Over 180,000 Georgians
have already cast their ballots
over the weekend,
taking advantage
of that extra day of early votin
that they got
because of that lawsuit
that was filed by Senator Warnoc
Did you agree with the judge's
ruling in that case?
I don't even know.
There was a discussion on that.
Look, people got plenty of time
to vote in this election.
Let them go vote.
This is going to be a turnout el
My message to people
is don't get distracted
with things like that.
Just get the vote out.
So you think it's good
that there was that
extra day of early voting?
Well, I mean, look, counties
have always had the option to ow
when they can do early voting or
So, I mean, I think fighting tha
we could have been doing other t
But, you know, look,
it wasn't my decision.
I wasn't involved in it.
All that matters is just on Elec
who's got the most votes
It's you know, it's really that
And I just think Republicans
don't need to get distracted.
That's what happened in the last
we had here in Georgia.
And it didn't turn out very good
Well, I want to return to that.
But since I have seen you,
you've won your reelection.
You got about 200,000
more votes than the Republican c
for Senate.
Herschel Walker did.
You're now
appearing with him on the campai
trail
in a much bigger way
than you were last when I saw yo
Why now?
And why do you think there were
people that voted for you,
but not for Herschel Walker?
Well, listen,
I was focused on making sure tha
I got reelected.
And I was also,
as you know, from our past inter
and what people saw us
doing in our campaign doing
it wasn't just helping me.
It was helping our whole ticket.
We had a really good night here
in Georgia.
We won every, you know,
statewide race Republicans did.
And then we got an incumbent U.S
senator in a runoff.
So we had an incredible night he
But really, to me, the runoff
now is a very simple choice.
You know,
are you going to vote for somebo
that's been with Joe
Biden 96% of the time,
or are you going to vote for som
that's going to go up there
and fight for Georgia?
And that's that's the way I'm vo
Well, Herschel
Walker was the only Republican
who did not win on November eigh
still on the statewide ticket.
What you just said about the cho
something you said
it reminds you,
on the campaign trail recently,
which was you said,
who do you want to fight for
you in the Senate?
Do you want a guy who represents
our values like Herschel Walker
or do you want somebody who has
with President Biden? 96% of the
Does Herschel Walker share your
Well, listen,
when I'm talking about going
to Washington, D.C.,
and fighting
for what
Georgians need, I'm
talking about the border.
40 year high inflation,
astronomical gas prices
since Joe Biden took office
and the agenda that Raphael Warn
has supported up there.
I mean, to me,
it's that simple in this race.
And that's you know what?
I'm voting for Herschel Walker.
I want somebody to go up there
and go fight for our state
and fight for our citizens,
not fight to support a president
that really, in my view,
is not upholding the values
of what Georgians want
and using Herschel Walker
does that when it comes to value
I think he will do that
in the United States Senate.
You're campaigning with
Herschel Walker,
but Senator Warnock has kind of
campaigning with you.
You have been featured in
some of his ads.
He is showing voters
who cast their ballots for you,
did a press conference talking a
you know,
me and my agenda, which,
you know, hopefully
because I did
that people will listen to
what I've been telling them to v
guys to go fight for us.
It's pretty
rare to see a Democratic Senate
campaigning with people who vote
for the Republican governor.
Well, yeah.
I mean, look,
Warren has got a lot of resource
He can do whatever he wants.
But at the end of the day,
I don't think any of that stuff
The money doesn't matter.
You know,
somebody whose views
that's going on a television
commercial doesn't necessarily m
It matters what people think
and what they're dealing with
in their everyday lives.
And I know people are dealing
with 40 year high inflation.
I know that.
They know that the borders of di
and you got Joe Biden
saying after the November electi
not going to change a thing.
And I just think
there's a lot of Georgians
that want things to change in Wa
D.C.
and they want people
fighting to
lower gas
prices and lower 40 year high in
Interest rates are going up.
I mean, it's
you know, a lot of people
starting to get laid off,
big companies that are out there
Thankfully, our economy
has been more insulated than mos
around the country.
And we're very thankful
and blessed by that.
But, you know, we don't want to
continuing into the future.
You talked about lessons
learned after the last runoff el
What are those lessons
Well,
I think that's one reason
we control our own destiny
on our ground game,
which we've,
you know, turn
that over to the Senate Leadersh
And they're they're out there wo
They're knocking doors.
We're getting people to the poll
which is what this race is all a
And we built something
pretty special here
that worked and didn't just work
It worked for the rest of the Re
on the state ticket.
And we're trying to make that wo
hopefully in this runoff.
We'll find out on next Tuesday.
Since I saw you, Georgia's
highest court
has reinstated a ban on abortion
after six weeks.
It basically put on
hold a decision
by a lower court
that overturned that 2019
law that you signed into law.
If the appeals court comes back
and overturns the law, what will
Well, we're
going to keep fighting the legal
I mean,
we knew three years ago
when we passed this bill
that it was going to take a long
to be
to get it through the courts
and to get it implemented.
And we knew there would be
a lot of people fighting us
But that's the path that we've t
and that's what we'll do.
And so we're just going to wait
what the court does.
And, you know, then we'll reasse
I believe that they'll uphold ou
and it'll be implemented.
Let me get your reaction to some
that former President Trump
has been under fire for in recen
which is having dinner
with Nick Fuentes, this outspoke
white supremacist, an anti-Semit
Well, I just put a statement out
I'll let that statement speak fo
I mean, that was a bad decision.
There's no place for that
in the Republican Party.
I know he's got,
you know, his answer to that que
And I'll let him speak to that.
But my views on that are very cl
He has defended it, saying
he was a guest of Kanye West,
who was his guest,
but he hasn't criticized or
denounced the statements
that we've seen as hateful langu
from the contest.
Well, listen, I am not privy to
who said what and all of that.
I'll just let my statement
speak for herself.
It's very clear
in recent days
you have filed paperwork
to create a federal PAC of your
Makes people
wonder if you've got
some of your own future
national ambitions.
What would you tell them?
I would tell them no.
We're working hard to get Hersch
Herschel Walker
elected to the United States Sen
And that's what people in
Georgia need to stay focused on.
We can cannot get distracted
with other things.
And so that PACs designed
to do that,
but also to help federal candida
in the future in our state
I mean, what we
built with our ground game
and the Georgians First
Committee was very effective
at the state level.
And we want to have that same to
available to help some of our fr
that may be serving in Congress
or perhaps,
you know, other nominees
or other folks in the future.
And so we thought it was wise
to do that, to capitalize off of
really a great effort
that we've put together and cont
to build off
that keep our state in good hand
and have people in Washington, D
that are voting Georgia values.
Could that be to help other peop
who are running
for the Republican nomination
for president potentially?
Well, that's not
that's not what the focus is.
You know,
you do not need to worry
about the next Tuesday.
That's what I'm worried about,
staying focused on.
Getting Herschel over the goal l
next Tuesday is obviously what
everyone's eyes are on.
But you did
see the former
president announce
that he will be running in 20, 2
he said decided that.
Would you support him in that ru
Well I seeing who else is going
So I'll keep focused on getting
to do nine states.
We do not need to get
distracted from that.